how did this running back go from
multiple drug suspensions in the NFL to
now owning his own successful cannabis
business Ricky Williams was a star of
Texas rushing for
1893 yards his junior year and winning
the Heisman right after after he was
drafted fifth overall by the Saints in
1999 he had a fairly successful career
until failed drug tests started to pile
up smoking weed before games was normal
for Ricky as he struggled with social
anxiety disorder borderline personality
disorder and more he was even high
before he broke Texas's single game
rushing record with 350 yards but once
he tested positive for marijuana
multiple times and violated the League's
policy he decided to hang up the cleats
after 11 Seasons the end of his NFL
career opened a door to launch his new
marijuana business Heisman fast forward
a few years later in Williams's business
not only sells marijuana but also has
merch for his brand his brand is an
expression of who he couldn't be in the
NFL and now the former Heisman winner is
the highest in the room